what's up reject nation alright so I see
here a Zack Snyder tweeted something out
it's now an HBO Max and funny enough I
actually said this in yesterday's video
I mean I would I imagine what we'll be
getting our trailers for trailers
leading up to this event of like a
little snippet or like fifteen to thirty
seconds tune in August 22nd for the DC
event you know we're gonna be doing a
lot of that but skeezy teases yeah it's
gonna be excited because actually for
the Snyder cut Department and already we
have a 30-second tease for what's to
come I can't wait to see what the third
let's check it out
that Lex Luthor Darkseid
[Music]
and hey watch that I get a lot is Luther
right
oh you could
my goodness you know a Justice League
dark apocalypse war being so loved such
a great animated film great time to be
excited for Darkseid to be coming to
Zack Snyder's Justice League a lot of
people are still pondering you know
after so many reports have come out and
so much information has been revealed
about how is this exactly gonna be
entirely different or whatever
especially according to zack snyder
saying that majority of it will be very
different I think this is a great 30
second teaser to cue you in as hey
there's like a whole missing plotline
here I mean you don't see Lex Luthor and
the Whedon cut until the post credits
scene and then I'm pretty sure that's
him talking there Darkseid who's not
present in in the film and then here you
see you see a clearer image of him I
know some people like I believe this
image was released online not long ago
and there were some complaints about
like why does Darkseid have a weapon I
don't know something like that doesn't
really bother me of people who's a lot
of people will step in and go Darkseid
doesn't know who honestly ever needed to
have a weapon in hand I know we'll just
see what's up maybe he doesn't even
really use it that often
y'all just cluing you in is into like
hey there's plot lines that haven't been
explored Darkseid's going to be in this
there's also the tone and the mood and
really having that apocalyptic war vibe
already just within 30 seconds there's a
lot here that is really showcasing for a
30-second tease this is going to be
something entirely different and man is
that junkie XL score that like
apocalyptic horror score this is so
exciting and like I said just everything
is smart about the marketing with this
especially with Justice League dark
apocalypse war being such a hit amongst
the DC fans like I said it yesterday's
video that the main thing I'm really
looking forward to come this DC fandom
event whatever full trailer we get of
the Snyder cut baby bring it on I cannot
wait all right guys what do you think of
this 30-second tease leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification where I got
notified
we got a YouTube video up catch you guys
soon